sag h schon immer oder das ist
Spiel was monkr mitbringen mega viel
Energie Motivation
freü
fre junge B und das Problem sie findet h
passende Partner oder Partnerin zum
gemeinsam derof
[Musik]
aber ja die Person B die personzug zu
dem G ich sing kan selber es ist nicht
einfach die richtig Partnerin finde aber
bit der Landwirt und Landwirtin ist der
perfekte Match besonders
schwierig super
sozialf aber es geht sch das die ganz
einsam was heißt das für pürine und pure
wenn sie Single bliebet ja mal
tinderprofil gemacht mit mit
der ich
[Musik]
tinder da auf dem urnb AL Wunschkonzert
große Volksmusik Party mir g word dass
ich da Land wir Treff zum
Date V das
[Applaus]
gan und sch
Musik tinder in real life mit wem gibt's
ein Match Flirt und tanzskills sind da
Höch im Kurs mir FT junge Frau wo man
selbstbewusst zum tanzu
[Applaus]
fordert ist die Motivation zum da geile
l geile Kollege t scha
landwirtschaftshof über je nachdem wenn
ich richtig für das B ma ich das ja
machen für das ich richtig oder so und
ist das ein zum das finde
ja die ganze
Zeit und rich
und er
sch nicht Kontakt sch sie während der
Tanzpause winkte mich zu sich es ist der
dan
ich ja top ja und sind Match
tan wie ist der Nacht wi gegangen und
was ist Match wordde ich verabschiede
mich von da mit dem zielenia und der dan
noals treffen ichl jetzt allererst
Alpabzug ich treffe und mir wander Stund
bis zu Al für das bin ich
20estanden ein mich am Bahnhof zarnen ab
mit schwest
hallo ohne freiwillig Unterstützig W
Alpabzug nicht möglich der dan schaff
Baumaschine Führer vor z Jahr hat
zusatzlich der Landwirtschaftsbetrieb
von der elterüber im Moment Bucht nur
die ganze Familie wom mit
hilft
machen
sind
[Musik]
relativ in den näch Jahr W Elter immer
meh Z und der Sohn s Betrieb ganz über
das W am Lib mit der Partnerin und da
sind wir wieder beim
Thema
v
num
nein nein
nichotz
Schle also sie wä
sch ja ja war sch Frau wo eine such mit
E Hof das GT
sch das ist
Spiel
s h schonmer oder du bist
sch ja
me Betrieb oder B weniger
spontan und
fre was du für
Fr
für wei doch
nicht
ja im besten Fall mitschaffen auf dem
Hof
ja ich
fre
macht aber
grundszlich
mewiig
mitber
oder und oder wenn ich
jetzt
oder Anita verhet mit und schaff auf
gemeinsam Betrieb dir du Partner genau
auf das dass er ein Hof hat oder
irgendwie dass er
Lifestyle du jetzt auch mitchaffen
ja und das ist entsche Punkt der
Part wo der Landwirtschaft n ST die
meiste auch ich kom ganz andere
Welt gwche
Verhaltensregel btim Rechte Frau versteh
ich
schon
wenig sch mal Bezirk
Jain
ja
ist sag jetzt die sch
Problem ja
s
ein
nicht
mit zweis BB dan wenig Z aktiv Partnerin
ich auf der baustell viig G direkt auf
der
[Musik]
Hof viel
imich und für mich ist es wenn ich jetzt
100% schaffe ist es für
[Musik]
mich bitte vergiss ich das wieder auf
passiert und umgekehrt
[Musik]
oder auf dem wagzug B Z zum Reflektieren
Partnerin ist keine einfache Sache
schätzes ist jeder vier bur oder bürin
Singel es muss so viel stimmen das
passt dazu dass re sucht was unchahof
mit dem ich fr mich ob überhaupt fre
Herz Entscheid
lich g l W der Volksmusik Party auch
ihres Lebes Glück gest
[Musik]
hat ich triffe sie und ihre Mutter auf
ihrof unter
hallo die 21jäh lenf Gesundheit und
schaff die freizit Betrieb ter mit
ih traumischesam mit Partner der Hof
zuübern am Wunschkonzert hat sie der ein
oder andere keine gelernt
und nein
nicht nicht
sch ja sch was müs mal konkret
mitbringen mega viel Energie
Motivation
fre
Berg sportlich muss
sicher Wand Sache
ja und muss s ke Hof genau das
praktisch
scho Hof jetzt da
[Applaus]
nichtheit wachsen ich habe ganze le
schon hier verbracht so sch
erinner ja W ich einfach meine Kind e
witer aber es W mega F wenn ich plar ke
um mich als wenn ich jetzt Bü aus mus
komplett
also vom Lifestyle oder von der Arbeit
her der
Naturverbundenheit V der Tier W ich mus
sag dir gab ein so so viel rür also ich
habe mit de Kusel und so und die hab
einfach an die sind einfach da und ich
hab Gefüh das git mir so viel
Sicherheit und Partner findig ich so
sicher nicht
einfach jeder machte das auch nicht mit
wir h hier strange Betrieb mehheitlich
nur stzigs Land und das ist auch nicht
jedem Mann
sach schon mal kennengelernt we ich cool
W aber dann h m sage ne das passt nicht
wie nicht das ja schon öfters und das
ich mega sch gefunden dass es dem Grund
nicht funktioniert h aber das machen
zwingen zum das zum das mit
machen machen früeg mit Freid
aber groß wei ja die Person Bü die
Person Bezug zu dem ganz sicher aber
andere
nicht meistens einfach die
[Musik]
Kollege
nur hat schwi Betrieb
fü Partner als Mitarbeiterin anstell
will nur dann hätte sie im Fall von
trinik unter anderem recht V Arbeitslose
geldt und wird von bessere vorsorg
profitieren lu Studie schaff eigentlich
all befrüte Frau v Landwirt auf purhof
mit fast HFT DAV ohne Lohn so aus Mami V
der len ist Thema D du
D n
Thema warum
nicht
das bist du weniger romantisch als
elfund bist pessimistisch oder ist
das bin und ich weiß einfach es so viin
inzwischen absicher für michber
ir und das ke
Lust es git immer mehr scheidige V der
Landwirtschaft und es zeigt sich dass es
B den schidiger R doppelt so hfig zu
rechtittt wie beim Rest von der bevölker
auch drum empfeht der
landfrauverband Partner od
sichell Partner s aber nicht nur
Landwirt sie er müsste mit ih ihr Elter
und ihr Großelter im gich Hus wohen also
das
istner das
W ein
war aber das nicht und darum das
Vorstellen
Generation
war das einfach find das mitmacht
nein gar nicht die m wet immerpruchsv
und wir sind heute hier einig V der
Straß zu und mit zu der Stadt aber wenn
es richtig ist würde das sich machen
mitmachchen und dann da noch zu dires
Kinderzimmer ja es GB
ein ja ist
BA GI die
sam im Sommer wenn ich ganz
alleid nicht da sind schon so wo mir
näch
nach so aber l ich meine Kollegen oder g
me Kollege einfach und der
got ist die Einsamkeit nicht me so groß
aber es git schon dass die ganz einsam
FL ja der näch doch erst da wieder erst
da ob W Schnick Meck doch B
Luf und das sind auch auch ter ich also
ich B der wir sind der die jüste und
schwieriger verwurzelt sie wo
aufgewachsen ist das gilt auch für Dan
mich mit aufhof K das für dich du vi
irgendw anders auf das H ich
eigentlich
ich
irgendw nichtade irgendwie
alles ja und bis wann ter
auf
ja
aber aber das war schon oder WN plzlich
irgend
plzlich
mit das
ist schlecht nach dem Video wir W sich
auf dich
stürzen
unter
anderem Ziel von Dan ist dass in Zukunft
stad Schwester Partnerin in B der Arbeit
unter dme grifft wie G das E mit wenn
Partnerin h sie stelle also wi der
lohnzahle ja
ja vorstellen fin
nein weniger meine wenn wenn
Sie wenn Sie l schaff aber mus nicht
daheim wenn
daheimis wenn sie DAV profitiere ne von
mir muss ich hier nicht
n Land Frauenverband
im Fall von der schid oder dass sie halt
abgesichert aber du bist bist
so aber das nicht
wenn gar
nicht D mir
eigentlich und
Problem das
ich nein eigentlich nicht also
[Musik]
ich dass der dan die richtig find
interessiert Familie schließlich g um
die Generation
Wechsel wie ist das für
dich Hof
übernimmt
sch macht
oder
ja mal Angst nicht ja Angst kann man
nicht
sagenang
schon machen und ja aber mE kann ich das
was
machen ja od wenn dan nicht über h was h
gemacht und pensioniert ja
verleen
Land
ja schon nicht so schnell
ja zwar n ni schwellig aber auf Dan l
der Druck Familie gründe damit die
Tradition wier
geht
oder sie muss kein Hof nein
mus ja mal tinderprofil gemacht mit mit
der
ich vielleicht
ein
wirklich also ich weiß nicht ke sch was
ich soüber Online Dating und das gelernt
das ja
bauerledigucht bist schon mal Word
ja ja bin ich schon und ne nicht leid
Plan B mit 4 ja ja ne mit war schn mit
30 und jetzt war aber sind z jah
Corona mit
näch
ja
also besser besser am nächste
Wunschkonzert rech
Druck genau
[Musik]
dieicht
extrem schön da mega
idisch Extremfall für verlänger
W wandere aber das lebe also ich bin
richtig froh bin ich nicht soesk zu
Partnerin such und ich meine da die
stadwohne mit der Aussicht ist nicht
mega schlimm oder wie G sind partn oder
Partnerin und K das dt sind spezifische
oder Lifestyle sch doch gerne Komment
und W me zum Thema von Landwirt und
Landwirtin
dannf Play und impact Reportage Burnout
und Depressionen in der Landwirtschaft